e
vous êtes tous tenir une de saveur
je te le dis femmes c'est des conneries
des grilles qui découvrent méprise
et si les hommes se croient n'allez pas
penser
homme solitaire j'ai vu des montagnes ce
soir avoir des ombres depuis leur comme
la lampe magique qui dévoile vos ordres
je t'aime tant qu étant que silencieux
je tourne nuit entière une des figures
comme un aventurier tenait étonné qu'il
y ait encore des prêts noir et battus
par des années que j'y passerais ma vie
sans que jamais je ne regrette
enfin
je veux connaître tes premiers cheveux
blancs
la douceur
déjà mais déjà la ville étoilés comme
les yeux d'un centre coup de filet de
sang déjà déjà odieux comme on était à
nuages noirs fait frissonner les pas et
attend les champs c'est comme cela que
les hommes
il couvre les traces de leurs distances
et dans cette fosse
alors il couvre le dire - leurs pertes
parce que
d'accord
ce
amal d'emea t'aimais je t'aime tu
entends
à malte est mis à t'aimer autant en
étant je vous ai trop dit le dicton
j'ai rêvé j'ai rêvé qu'un seul de ces
gestes soient le ralenti de ma vie
partir